So let's discuss the memory ordering quiz solution for
this. In this situation there is a store and
then a load to the same address, so the
load obviously doesn't go to cache or memory to
get its value. It's going to get it from the
store. But where does the store keep its value?
The store doesn't broadcast the result. The result is
broadcast for instructions that produce register result. So the store
really never broadcasts its results. So this
is definitely not true. A reservation station, reservation
stations never provide any results to subsequent instructions.
They only keep values captured for the current
instruction. The store doesn't even have a reservation
station. So this is definitely not correct. A
ROB entry would keep a result for a
register producing instruction between the time it's been
broadcast and the time it commits. But because
a store is not a register value producing instruction,
it doesn't put its result in a ROB
entry, in fact, technically, the store doesn't have a
result. So this is not correct. The store
does keep the values going to store in the
low store Q, and if you remember, that
is where the load searches for a value when
it's trying to match its address to addresses of
previous stores. So this is the only correct answer.